again just action reaction drill
it's not the opponent so i'm here
i push he pushes back into me you're
gonna have your other hand
and push pushes back into me i'm gonna
yield it
and come right into the kitchen
[Music]
to feel the pressure he goes right
same size pressure
it right into it
same side pressure
yield it boom right into it
other side boom pressure
yielded right into it
other side get your other hand up
boom pressure yielded
into it same side
pressure yield you're looking right here
action reaction okay
so i'm pushing here i
i don't want to go like this do
a technique i
push i feel him push and it goes right
into
that that's what i'm doing so i push i
feel him push and that little fit
is what i used to go into it
again won't that little bit
right into it
here get his arm come around again
a little push he pushes back right into
it
okay let's go on this one i'm coming in
to neil okay
so i'm trying to do that he's trying to
keep his posture
so i'm trying to pull him he resisted
i entered
i'm going like this he's trying to
keep this posture you don't have to jerk
it so then i use that
okay let's go okay so i'm here
i'm trying the arm drag he's resisting
don't let your arm
the other arm go dead okay so well
i tried it and that's where i go
and what i'm working on is uh
some here is how seamless this is not
seamless
anymore okay so home it goes right in
he can only fool me why because i'm
staying back here
okay if if i blend with that
i'm just matching
he went in i went young
right here
try to show you your reaction
again i think i'm beating
yes
yes okay let's go
over here this is this is my technique
so he's got a good grip he has a script
there
i come in boom i pull it off okay
then i'm gonna try to drag it across
takes roses back okay so i go
boom but he resists you see
and i go into
don't lose the elbow because that's the
control point
boom keep the elbow
you still have the elbow
okay let's go just because i'm doing the
action reaction set up
okay let's do this
so just because i'm going from here
trying to get that lower your balance
there you go
okay so i'm trying to get that
and he resists it's not that i'm coming
in here
and going what
there is still the yielding
the body trap the ground vectoring it's
not now
a clash okay so
when i go here boom i still this
i still got your back please come back
just protect your back okay
oh pop i got it again
got it again protect your back
third time you're not gonna lie
boom there when i come in i still make
contact
and i still go around his energy
don't wwe eat him
whoa
still around
different i'm not doing that
so keep to your arc
okay let's go okay so here i'm trying
this
this is the simple drive and trip that
way
he's gonna resist and trying to drive
back
so you need when i go and he drives back
i go in
then we're just doing a drill so he's
going to lock his body
get a good grip on me and i'm going to
lower him
oh i drive he drives burn
then we're back in drill
good luck i lowered don't lose the elbow
control
it goes this arm goes up i go underneath
then we're back in a drill
action reaction drill
let's go